mayor Pete says God has no political
party Kamala Harris flip-flops once more
and Democrats prepare further
investigations i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show and a lot happening
in the news we'll get to all of it in
just one second first we're never going
to agree on everything but i think we
can all agree that we could all use more
sleep certainly i agree with me on that
getting a great night's sleep is easier
and more affordable than you think you
don't need a new expensive mattress or
sleeping pills you need to change the
sheets that's why you should check out
bull and branch bull and branches the
best sheets on the market everything
bull and branch makes from bedding to
blankets is made from pure 100% organic
cotton which means they start out super
soft they get even softer over time
you buy directly from them so you're
essentially paying wholesale prices
luxury sheets can cost up to a thousand
dollars in the store poland brand sheets
are only a couple of hundred bucks
everyone who tries Boleyn branch sheets
loves them which is why they have
thousands of five-star reviews even
three u.s. presidents sleep on bull and
branch sheets shipping is free you can
try them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send them back for a refund but I
doubt you're gonna want to send them
back there is no risk no reason to not
give them a try to get you started right
now my listeners can get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets at bull and
branch calm promo code Benton that's
bull and branch calm for 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets bull and branch
calm today Bo ll and branch comp Ramona
Ben my wife and I have these sheets we
actually took all our other sheets and
threw them out Boleyn branch will ruin
your other sheets for you they are that
good check them out right now bull and
branch comm from a code ban go check
them out and enjoy a better night's rest
okay so I want to begin today by talking
about a point that was made by Peter
Budaj
mayor Pete the man who is the man of the
hour in democratic media the guy who is
rising from the crowd he's never any
third in Iowa after Bernie and Biden he
is running maybe third nationally after
Bernie and Biden and he's come out of
nowhere because obviously he is the
mayor of South Bend Indiana a town that
is smaller than probably my district in
in California in terms of population
almost certainly my district in
California in terms of population that's
pretty astonishing and it has to do with
a couple of facts fact number one he's
very articulate guy dude knows how to
speak he knows how to handle himself he
has very strong intellectual background
I went to Harvard he's a Rhodes Scholar
studied at Oxford University very smart
guy
point number two he's gay and that means
he has intersectional credibility he
needs both of these things if you were
just a gay guy who did not have this
sort of articulate Ness he would not be
succeeding if he were an articulate guy
who are not gay he would be going
nowhere inside a Democratic primary that
values intersectionality above all else
intersectionality radicalism or name
recognition right those are the top
three right there intersectionality
people who to judge radicalism Bernie
Sanders or name recognition Joe Biden
well Buddha judge is gaining an enormous
amount of credibility in the media too
because members of the media have long
been seeking a spokesperson for their
bizarre views on religion their bizarre
view of religion is this you can call
yourself a Christian or a Jew and you
can have you can pick and choose which
views you want to abide by in the Bible
you can call yourself biblically
illiterate you can call yourself a Bible
believer you can call yourself
biblically adherent while ignoring vast
swathes of the Bible in favor of your
preferred leftist politics this is
something that happens widely in the
Jewish community is also happening
increasingly in the Christian community
now let me make this clear I do not
believe that religion ought to be
discussed as a matter of politics I
don't whenever I make a political
argument
I don't like God to back my political
argument nor do I cite the Bible to back
my political arguments why because it's
not it's not effective it's not
effective it's not useful many people do
not share that frame I'm arguing based
on Authority if I do that and that
authority is not held by everyone so a
proper response to what I'm about to say
is God doesn't exist or I'm an atheist
that's fine yeah that doesn't matter you
and I can have a political conversation
without invoking God in fact as I say I
prefer those sorts of conversations
because I think that those are the ones
public policy should generally be based
on every single public policy should
have a secular rationale to support it I
say this as a religious person I do not
believe that invoking the Bible is any
sort of argument for a public policy
decision I don't
so put that to one side there a group of
people on the Left who really really
really wants to be able to reach out to
religious people by telling those
religious people they have gotten their
interpretation of text wrong for the
last several thousand years and those
people are not truly religious truly
religious people would be secular
leftist truly religious people would be
people who say that they believe in the
Bible but then read out broad swaths of
the Bible and Mayor Pete is the mayor
and for them mayor Pete is the guy who
is the youth pastor from Sunday school
at an Episcopalian Church who will tell
you all about how much pizza and guitar
are great and how much God loves you and
also we have no standards for behavior
here everyone is welcomed everyone is
loved and sin is not really a thing that
you should worry about you should really
just find yourself now that is not a
true biblically-based perspective the
Bible says things I think we could all
agree the Bible says things okay and
those things that the Bible says are
supposed to be taken seriously so again
I'm not speaking to people who believe
in a generic version of God not speaking
through the Bible Buddha judge proclaims
that he is a Christian that means that
purportedly he takes the Bible seriously
both the old and the New Testaments this
is one of the requirements for being a
Christian well folks on the Left don't
want to take that they want to say I'm a
Christian because I believe in Jesus but
not because of any of the other stuff
all of the other stuff is uncomfortable
all the other stuff makes me feel weird
all of the other stuff has moral
standards attached to it and this is why
mayor Pete has become their guy because
mayor people go out there and say I am
also a Christian I'm a deeply believing
Christian and also I don't abide by any
of the traditional categories of sin not
on traditional sexual mores not a mores
certainly not on abortion not on the
traditional definition of gender which
also happens to be the biological
definition of gender mayor Pete
basically says yes on Jesus no on
everything else and this is something
that the media love the media are very
intimate they would like to see religion
moved in this direction now religion has
been moving in this direction in the
United States and that is why you have
been seeing adherence to the church
running screaming away from the church
this is why you have been seeing the
increase in second words of an atheism
because the only dividing line between
seculars and an atheists and the sort of
religion that Mayor Pete is promoting
here is belief in God because the
principles are exactly the same it's
just do you want God or do you not want
God if you don't want God then you say
well I'm tough minded and I don't want
God I don't think God is necessary I
think that he is the the thesis that is
that is unnecessary the unnecessary
thesis in the in the language of Laplace
and so I'm an atheist or I'm a
secularist and if you believe in God you
say well I want a spiritual life I
believe there's something beyond so I
believe in God but this God doesn't mean
that I have to do anything or if I do
have to do something it's only the more
soft emotionally driven Commandments
anything that demands and
thing of me know anything that says be a
more humble human being in concert with
the universe and all of that kind of
stuff the sort of stuff that you could
get from marianne williamson lecture
that sort of stuff we will find in the
bible so the reason that I bring this up
is because there is a in active attempt
by members of the media to promote mayor
Pete's version of religion as the true
version of religion and Mike Pence's
version of religion or the traditional
view of religion or biblical scholars
view of religion as a sort of intolerant
sham there's a dark underbelly to this
attempt ok the dark underbelly to this
attempt is the attempt to suggest that
if you believe in traditional notions of
sin this is because you are a bigot and
you are simply covering for your bigotry
with God's language basically you're
using religious and religion as an
excuse to be a bigot this is what backs
a lot of the push for
anti-discrimination law that targets
religious people this is what backs the
idea from so many people that if you
believe for example that same-sex
marriage is sinful I I'm a libertarian
on same-sex marriage when it comes to
government again I think all arguments
in public policy realms need secular
rationales but when it comes to my
personal view of sin because I'm a
biblically live biblically living and
believing Jew I believe that homosexual
activity is a sin the left wants to
suggest that that is just thinly veiled
bigotry that even if I didn't believe
that stuff then I would still believe
that homosexuality was wrong simply out
of bigotry not of and not out of any
natural beliefs not of any
traditional philosophical beliefs simply
out of sheer hatred and bigotry this is
what undergirds a lot of the argument
being made in favorable mayor Pete is
saying so I keep invoking may repeat the
reason I invoke mayor Pete is because
this is the hard push that he has been
making now for weeks and months and the
media have picked up on it and amplified
it so here is is Budaj edge yesterday
suggesting that God has no political
party you know it can be challenging to
be a person of faith who's also part of
the LGBTQ community and yet to me the
the core of faith is regard for one
another and part of how God's love is
experienced according to my faith
tradition is in the way that we support
one another and in particular support
the least among us one of the things
about Scripture has different people see
different things in it but at the very
least
we should be able to establish that God
does not have a political party okay
there are a couple of things there that
are very much worthy of note and go to
this underlying conflict over religious
philosophy number one mayor Pete's
version of religion is the same as
Barack Obama's version of religion or
Hillary Clinton's version of religion
they're gonna quote one verse from
Matthew about the least among us and
then they're going to ignore the rest of
the entire Bible that is gonna be the
thing we have to treat people so they're
going to conflate treating people with
respect or tolerance with treating their
sin with respect or tolerance so
therefore if you see somebody in front
of you who you believe is committing a
sin even if you treat them nicely but
you don't accept that their sin is
decent then this means that you are not
respectful or tolerance that of course
is untrue I as a religious Jew I've said
this before you can watch me on Dave
Rubens show as a religious Jew I believe
homosexual activity is a sin I have many
many many gay friends the reason that
that is relevant is because I treat gay
people very well just the way I would
treat everybody else because it turns
out that lots of people that I know sin
in a variety of ways of which I do not
approve I still treat them really well
that does not mean that I have to think
that their sins are no longer sins just
as they they don't have to take
seriously my religious point of view
differences of opinion are fine so long
as we treat each other with a certain
modicum of respect now that modicum of
respect does not mean I have to violate
my religion it doesn't mean I have to
attend a gay wedding it doesn't mean
that I have to cater my services to a
same-sex wedding it doesn't mean that I
have to bake a cake for a gender
transition ceremony I don't have to do
any of those things that is not a demand
of respect that's a demand of service
demand of service is not the same as a
demand of respect respect just means I
have to treat you just as I would any
other human being when I deal with you
interpersonally it does not mean that I
have to leverage my behavior or my
activities on behalf of your specific
sin which is why I've said to my friend
Dave Rubin I'm more than happy to go out
to dinner with you and your husband I'm
not willing to go to your gay wedding
because one is the celebration of
something that i religiously consider
sinful and the other is just me going
out with my friends and if they commit a
sin that's on them I mean that's not
really my responsibility these
distinctions matter because what's the
underlying drive here is two paints all
religious people as bigots as
intolerance so if I don't do what you
want me to do I'm a bigot and I mean and
I'm intolerant I have a right to think
I want about a behavior in which you
engage and you have a right to think
that my religion is stupid you have a
right to think whatever you want and if
you want to have a diverse worldview if
you want to have a diverse society
you're going to need to accept that
other people may not think of sin in the
same way that you think of sin and so
long as we all treat each other decently
when we interact with one another
without necessarily green-lighting each
other sins or each other's philosophies
then we can have a perfectly nice
society if not things are gonna get
really ugly really quickly now in a
second I want to explain the second part
of Buddha judgement statement where he
says that God has no political party
which i think is half true and 100%
disingenuous I'll explain in just one
second first let's talk about making
your business better
Zipp recruiter okay if you want to make
your hiring process easier you need to
use zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
zip recruiter sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards they
don't stop there but they're powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates see never miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective have four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that's zip recruiter com
slash Dai ly WI re zip recruiter com
slash daily Wire zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire go check them
out right now and try them for free at
zip recruiter comm slash daily wear
whenever we are looking to upgrade at
the daily wire offices or hire new
people we go and check out zip recruiter
comm slash daily where you should - zip
recruiter comm slash daily wear okay so
the second half of a mayor pizza
statement there where he suggests that
god has no political party as I say that
it's half true and it's a hundred
percent disingenuous so it is half true
because yes God did not say you must
vote Democrat or you must vote
Republican God says that you have free
will you can choose whichever nor does
God give statements about the party
platforms of the two parties but if you
are a Bible believer and again this is
all this entire conversation is in the
context of defining Bible believing it's
in the context of defining
judeo-christian
so if you don't believe in the Bible if
you don't believe in judeo-christian
values this conversation is not for you
and as I say this is not an argument
that every voting decision must be
predicated on your belief in
judeo-christian values you can just say
I don't vote along the lines of my
religion
that's fine you can say I don't vote
along the lines of judeo-christian
values that's fine too it's a free
country the point that I'm making is
that if you're like mayor Pete and
they're going to invoke judeo-christian
values and the biblical God in order to
back your position as mayor Pete does on
a routine basis it's a package deal you
know get to pick and choose when I say
that mayor Pete leverages his political
leverages his religion on behalf of his
politics on a routine basis I mean it so
for example Pete Buddha judge said just
the other day that he is faithful
because he is humble
whereas President Trump is not he said
this in the same interview on CNN part
of where I'm coming from is a faith
tradition that counsels me to be as
humble as possible that counsels me to
look after those who need defending and
frankly it couldn't be more radically
different than what I see certainly in
this White House where there's a lot of
chest thumping and self-aggrandizing
not to mention abusive behavior so
president Trump obviously does not
believe in God whereas people who judge
believes in God that's that's according
people to judge he's the one making the
religious arguments right now so since
Buddha judge is going to make religious
arguments I'm going to make religious
counter arguments when he says that he
is humble there's nothing less humble
than I can imagine that I can imagine as
a religious person then going in and
willy-nilly rewriting 3,000 years of
biblical history that seems pretty non
humble to me and as you'll see people
who judge does this on a routine basis
so I'm not a big believer that Donald
Trump is a religious man in any
traditional sense I don't think that he
believes in traditional definitions of
sin either or if he does I don't think
that he abides by them he's a sinner in
the way that everybody else is a sinner
maybe more so but that isn't but for
Buddha judge to stand there and say I am
a humble servant
whereas Donald Trump is an arrogant man
okay he may be more humble than Trump in
some ways he is not more humble in the
sense that Donald Trump is not the one
coming forward and saying oh yeah these
millions of believers who have believed
this stuff for the last 3,000 years and
it's written in the text I'm just gonna
override all of that because that's how
I feel about things
that seems pretty arrogant to me
I'll show you evidence of this arrogance
in just one second so evidence of people
judges arrogance number one people to
judge is in favor of late term abortion
now you again you can argue God has no
political party because God doesn't say
in the Bible vote Republican or vote
Democrat but God does have principles in
the Bible that is not silence on issues
of morality in the Bible the Bible is a
long long morally based document it
establishes a system of ethics and
morality God has things to say about
issues that affect us now religious
values do have implications for politics
so for example if you are religious
believer you cannot read the Bible and
come away with it's okay to abort a baby
at any point during the during the term
there's just no way you can do that
there's no way you can do that whether
you are reading Psalms or whether you're
reading or whether you're reading the
Old Testament or whether you're reading
the New Testament there is just nothing
in there there is nothing in there that
suggests that you can abort a fully
grown baby inside the womb nothing hey
there is nothing in the old or New
Testament that suggests that homosexual
activity is not sinful for example now
again you don't have to agree with any
of this that's fine that's your
prerogative and this doesn't have to
have implications for public policy but
what you cannot do is claim that a
religious perspective says X because I
want it to say acts and you cannot claim
if you claim to believe in the
judeo-christian tradition that God is
silent on these issues because God is
not silence on these issues by the way
you can believe that something is a sin
without government having to legislate
it I'm a libertarian I believe that
people are basically allowed to sin so
long as they are not harming anyone else
which is why I was libertarian on
same-sex marriage before oberst oh and
why I have been in favor of legislation
barring abortion since forever because
one harms a human and another is a
consensual relationship there's a
difference in terms of secular public
policy I never make a religious
arguments on this sort of stuff but from
a religious perspective
God is not silence on either of these
issues God is not silent on the issue of
for example the differences between the
sexes male and female he created them
right God is not silent on this if you
are a Bible believer that is not silence
on the idea of government's fixing all
of your problems God does not believe
that government ought to fix all of your
problems
God believes that God is God not
government as God God certainly doesn't
believe in anti religious discrimination
which is something that
pratik party seems very much in favor of
these days so if you were going to match
up God's priorities with party
priorities that's something that every
religious person is going to have to do
so when Buddha judge says God has no
political party that's his easy
sloganeering way of of ignoring the fact
that if you're a religious person you
have to match up your values with a
party that matches your values right God
doesn't have a political party but God
does have values and you as a human
being are gonna have to decide which of
these two parties mirrors those values
better and that's that's perfectly
logical and as I tweeted out yesterday I
agree God doesn't have a political party
and maybe you believe that God is more
concerned about tax rates progressive
tax rates then he is about abortion I'd
have to see the evidence for that but if
you believe that make that argument but
I can tell you this there is no evidence
that God would support a party that
supports infanticide late term abortion
same-sex marriage and in the end more
than same-sex marriage the use of
same-sex marriage to cram down against
religious institutions practices that
violate their specific beliefs
anti-discrimination laws that target
religious people there's no evidence
that they would back the trends to that
God would be super in favor of the
abolition of sex of biological sex and
so God does have perspectives I know
there are a lot of people out there who
are like why are you talking about God
because Buddha judge is talking about
God on this program go back listen to
the entire history of the program the
number of times I've mentioned God on
this program in a religious context in a
truly religious context probably it's
less than than the number of fingers on
my hands in the course of the 4-year
history of this program but I'm
mentioning it now because Buddha judges
trying to make a move that I think is
actually philosophically dangerous so
here and here's an example so Buddha
judge says God has no political party
and then he's asked ok fine so what does
God say about abortion listen to him
stumble over this your candidacy now
officially has also piqued the interest
of religious conservatives they talk
about the sanctity of life and they
can't get past your support of late term
abortion what do you say to them to me
it's very it's a very complex issue that
should be guided by a very simple
principle which is that having these
things dictated by government does not
make that decision any easy
in some ways some of these questions are
their religious or metaphysical however
you want to put them they're not things
that are knowable in a traditional sense
list of people who would criticize that
they said actually it is a pretty easy
answer these are the women facing some
of the most unbelievably excruciating
decisions and this is why Buddha judges
being arrogant and this is why he's
being a liar he's being a liar when it
comes to religion if he wants to say I
disagree with the traditional religion
on abortion that's fine but you can't
say that someone says something that
they do not that's unfair and it's wrong
whether you're quoting the Bible or they
are quoting another person to quote
somebody and say this is what they're
saying when that is not what they are
saying is silly when Buddha judge
suggests that he has a religious set of
values and then he's asked directly
about abortion and he said he
immediately reverts to Nair all
pro-choice America language he at least
has to acknowledge the conflict as I say
before it is not a sign of in fact and
dennis prager this is a religious
scholar he has an entire series coming
out with with commentaries on the Bible
his interpretation of the commandment in
the Bible but thou shalt not bear false
witness or that show is actually thou
shalt not use God's name in vain that
particular commandment thou shalt not
use God's name in vain then this is
interpretation I think this is largely
backed by the text and I think that
ideologically is correct is that using
God's name in vain is not about you
shouting gee dammit right it's not about
you using God's name in the middle of a
curse or something just saying God bleep
that's not what taking God's name in
vain means Dennis says and I think this
is correct they're taking God's name in
vain is quoting in the name of God the
reverse of what God says so saying that
God says X when in reality God says not
X is a sign of deep intellectual
arrogance not a sign of humility so does
God have a political party no does God
have principles yes do you have to
decide how those principles apply to
modern day politics absolutely if this
is something you care about and if you
don't care about it good for you that's
fine you don't have to but people who to
judge keep suggesting that he is
speaking from a religiously based
perspective okay well then he's going to
have to explain how that meshes with the
Bible itself
this is his standard not mine I don't
have to explain how my perspectives
match up with the Bible because I don't
say that my secular standards
match up with the Bible he has a very
easy answer on all of this stuff by the
way and his very easy answer is yes I'm
a religious person but I don't believe
that religion ought to have any impact
on public policy yet it's very easy for
him to say that he won't say that
because he is attempting to twist the
very nature of what religious practice
is to fit his definition of politics so
he can appeal presumably to people who
believe that religion and politics are
deeply intertwined that's that's a it's
a clever move but it's not an honest
move okay in a second we're gonna talk
about the other 2020 Democratic
candidates because this race is heating
up first let's talk about Dollar Shave
Club
I love the Dollar Shave Club has
everything I need to look feel and smell
my best what I love even more is the
fact that I never have to go to a store
that's because first yes he delivers
everything I need directly to my door
and second they keep me fully stocked on
what I use so I don't run out here's how
it works
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready no matter what you're
getting ready for they've got you
covered head-to-toe hair skin face you
name it they've got it and they have
this new program where they
automatically keep you stocked up on the
products you use you determine what you
want when you want it it shows up right
at your door from once a month to once
every six months that's what I do for
their amber lavender body cleanser it is
delightful plus with their handsome
discount the more you buy the more you
save and right now they've got a bunch
of starter sets you can try for just
five bucks like their oral care kit
after that the restock box ships regular
size products at regular price so what
exactly are you waiting for get your
starter set for just five bucks right
now at dollarshaveclub.com slash pen
that is dollarshaveclub.com slash men go
check them out right now
dollarshaveclub.com slash men when you
use that slash pen you can get that
starter set for just five bucks and then
the restock box chips regular size
products at regular price go get the
special deal right now at
dollarshaveclub.com
slash Ben all righty meanwhile the other
Democratic candidates are having a
little bit of trouble so Joe Biden is
preparing to launch his campaign he's
supposed to launch his campaign tomorrow
with some sort of online video and then
the idea is that he's gonna travel to
Pennsylvania and he's going to give his
first address in some sort of
Philadelphia Union Hall which is exactly
where he should right I mean that is
that is the smart political move his
base is gonna be in Pennsylvania and
Michigan and Wisconsin at least that is
the case that he is making he can win
back the state's the president Trump won
when he broke the so-called blue wall
while Biden is set to announce on
Thursday with an online video according
to people familiar with the plans they
are reporting it to
CNN the former VP steam has been laying
the campaign groundwork for months with
Biden's decision growing less secretive
or suspenseful by the day but now that
he has given the green light to his
advisor says CNN Biden is facing one of
the biggest challenge of his
half-century career in politics he's
scheduled to hold his first campaign
event in Pittsburgh on Monday sorry not
Philadelphia Pittsburgh a source said he
plans to hit the road to early voting
states of Iowa South Carolina and New
Hampshire in the coming days his
political action committee American
possibilities sends an email to
supporters on Tuesday to urge them to
sign up for the news well cut to the
chase the message said there's been a
lot of chatter about what Joe Biden
plans to do as one of Joe's top
supporters we want you to be the first
to know he's jumping into a race already
in progress likely becoming me xx
Democrats to declare candidacy
he's closely watched the campaign from
the sidelines aides say following the
policy debates and the introduction of
rising stars less than half his age this
will mark his third run for the White
House everything is different this time
because this time he was vice president
for Barack Obama although he ran in 88
and 2008 and was a giant fail now
everyone is sort of forgetting that Joe
Biden is a terrible campaigner everybody
seems to be forgetting the fact that he
is good as a VP campaigner because he's
not the guy at the top of the ticket
people weren't voting for Joe Biden in
2008 or 2012 they were voting for Barack
Obama if they've been voting for Joe
Biden it doesn't go quite the same way
people only like Joe Biden when he is
talking about other people when Joe
Biden talks about himself he is far less
popular which is why he was a fail in
1988 and had to drop out over a
plagiarism scandal and then in 2008 he
botched it within the very beginning of
the of the run by suggesting that Barack
Obama was the first quote clean and
articulate black man ever run for
presidents of the United States Joe
Biden is a gaffe machine people forget
this the more he is on the stump the
more he will gaffe the more yes the more
there will be people like khipu to judge
waiting in the wings to stab in the back
Joe Biden also has made a strategic
mistake here
he waited too long to get in because
there is a lingering question whether he
can fundraise particularly in small
dollars there are a lot of Democratic
bigwigs who want to get behind him but
how many of the truly motivated base
players are ready to hand their five or
ten dollars to him Bernie Sanders has
tons of those people how many of those
people are gonna turn to Joe Biden
I wonder there's 20 candidates in this
race everybody has their own particular
favorite the polls are split 1000
different ways
and that means the Joe Biden is gonna
have to suck up an inordinate number of
dollars to truly do damage at least from
the grassroots I'm not sure he does that
as I say I think that the best day for
Joe Biden may be his first day now he is
getting some help apparently from the
University of Delaware
according to Brent cher over at the free
beacon the University of Delaware
library is in possession of nearly 2,000
boxes of archival records covering Joe
Biden's 36 years as a senator but has
not committed to releasing them before
the presidential election and this is
insane you have thousands of pages at
the University of Delaware which I
believe is a state school input and
they're not gonna release it before the
election what is this nonsense the same
people who are fighting mad the Donald
Trump has never released his tax returns
are now saying that they want to cover
up thousands of pages of Joe Biden's
Senate records those things should be a
matter of public record I mean he does
have a library the records were donated
by Biden to his alma mater during his
first term as vice president in 2011
Biden stipulated when he donated the
papers the release could come no sooner
than two years after Biden retires from
any public office according to the
library well Biden left office January
20th 2017 but now the library says that
they have made a new agreement with Joe
Biden to keep the archive closed until
at least the end of the year why would
they make that new agreements exactly
why would they do that I mean they don't
have to the agreements already over and
this sets a pretty bad precedent which
is you turn your papers over and then
you just don't do and then you dictate
that they can never become public so
then what was the purpose of you turning
them over the Biden senatorial papers
are indeed still closed pending the
completion of processing still underway
and as per our agreement with the donor
which is that the papers would remain
closed until the later date of December
31st 2019 or two years after the donor
retires from public service
they say that they won't guarantee the
archive would open to the public
immediately once the Biden imposed
deadline had passed in a Thursday
morning email the head of the library
said there were no other stipulations on
the release of papers made by the donor
last is it last December the university
launched the Joseph R Biden School of
Public Policy and administration so he
has a pretty cozy relationship obviously
with the University of Delaware so what
exactly does Joe Biden have to hide in
those Senate records who the hell knows
and meanwhile Bernie Sanders has more to
hide
it turns out that Bernie Sanders has
been drawing his mayoral pension it's
wonderful to be a socialist when here at
the top of the chain when you're at the
top of the government chain then you get
to live high on the hog it's one of the
beautiful things about being a socialist
socialists liked to rail about income
inequality the true income inequality in
a socialist countries everybody else
living in penury
and you living off the government
largesse off taxpayer dollars Bernie
Sanders has been drawing hundreds of
thousands of taxpayer dollars for the
last four decades and now he complains
that America just isn't generous enough
it turns out that Sanders who earns a
hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars a year as a senator received
about five thousand dollars from
Burlington Vermont pension system in
2018 he is still drawing a pension for
his eight-year stints from the 1980s as
mayor of Burlington he could forgo that
a Bernie forgo a buck are you kidding
I wrote the best-selling book I will not
give that money up his total income with
his wife last year or the or in 2018 was
561 thousand dollars that was down from
the more than 1 million dollars they
earned in the prior two years largely as
a result of his book about running for
president in 2016 the practice is not
illegal it's not unknown in Congress
either there are a bunch of people in
Congress who double-dip but it doesn't
look great it doesn't look great in fact
former Obama administration official Rho
canna conducting a challenge to
incumbent Representative Mike Honda of
California blasted his fellow Democrat
Honda for double dipping
well Rho canna is now part of Sanders
his second bid for the White House he's
one of four national co-chairs of
Sanders his campaign so I guess his
perspective on double dipping has gone
completely by the wayside David Sirota
told CNBC quote like other past
Burlington mayor senator Sanders
receives a municipal pension for his
service as mayor of Burlington wonderful
that the people of Burlington can
continue to pay Bernie Sanders he's
raking in millions of dollars their
$5,000 a year because he once served as
mayor back when I was in diapers
so that's that's pretty exciting stuff
in a second we'll get to some of the
other Democratic candidates Kamala
Harris having a rough go of it basically
every time Komal Harris says anything
she has to back crack it within 24 hours
it's actually a rule of her campaign
we'll get to that in just one second
first remember when the left called the
green New Deal bold how about their bold
defense of anti-semitism in the house
how about
their definition of bold is just wrong
the way I defined bold that's the taste
of freedom I get every morning with my
black rifle coffee black rifle coffee is
the best coffee on the market it tastes
great the founders of it are awesome
dudes black rifle coffee gives a portion
of their sales to veterans and first
responder causes black rifle coffee is
roasted order guaranteeing you fresh
delicious coffee with every order black
rifles coffee club makes things easy
just pick your blend in the amount you
want black rifle ships your coffee
direct your door every month hassle-free
for a bold cup of America's best coffee
visit black rifle coffee common slash
Ben get 20% off your first purchase that
is black rifle coffee calm slash Ben for
20% off your first purchase
black rifle coffee calm / bed and go
check them out right now this is the
best coffee on the market and again it's
a great company a great American company
founded by awesome Americans and they
give a portion of their sales to
veterans and first responder causes you
got nothing to lose it is awesome
go check them out right now at black
rifle coffee calm / Ben get 20% off your
first purchase when you do black rifle
coffee dot-com rose to order fresh
delicious coffee with every order black
rifle coffee calm / ban ok so we have a
lot more to get to on today's show but
you're gonna have to subscribe daily
where daikon $9.99 a month gets you the
rest of the show two additional hours of
the show every afternoon now this week
I'm off from my radio show because of
Passover I've decided to take a little
bit of relaxation time with the family
but you can still get two additional
hours of other hosts I think it's Jason
Rance today or Jeremy boring hosted it
yesterday I'll have to find out for you
in any case next week we'll be back with
the two additional hours every afternoon
you get to be part of our mailbag you
get all sorts of wonderful goodies in
when you subscribe annual you get this
the very greatest in beverage vessels
the leftist here's hot or cold tumblr
test her eyes upon it and despaired that
you have it not but you could have it if
you got the annual subscription so what
exactly are you waiting for it gives you
strength of mine peace of soul
none of those guaranteed go check it out
right now left this year's Hydra called
tumblr for 99 bucks a year makes
julienne fries all sorts of wonderful
things so also subscribe at YouTube and
iTunes make sure that you leave us a
review we always appreciate it by the
way we're according to statistics the
second most downloaded news podcasts in
America for the entire last month
following only the New York Times as the
daily so help us there go check us out
YouTube and iTunes we always appreciate
it we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative
podcast and radio show in the United
States
[Music]
all righty so Elizabeth Warren is in the
race baiter O'Rourke's in the race bill
de blasio is in the race but the rest of
the 2020 Democratic candidate field is
led by Kamala Harris of Carmel Harris
has an unfortunate habit the senator
from California says things and then she
realizes they are dumb things and then
she walks back to dumb things so she has
done this multiple times already in the
race virtually every time she appears on
CNN she feels like she has to appease
the crowd that is in front of her and
then she has to walk it back so you'll
remember that last time she was on CNN
for her Town Hall she suggested she
wanted to do away with all private
health insurance plans and then within a
week she backtracked that by saying well
maybe we could do that but maybe we
won't do that well in the last 48 hours
she was on CNN saying that we should
seriously study the question as to
whether terrorists sitting in prison
like the Boston Marathon bomber ought to
be able to vote from prison and then she
realized oh this is a bad idea and then
she walked it back it's it's that kind
of decisive leadership I think America
is really seeking and looking for the
decisive leadership of Kamala Harris who
will decisively steer in one direction
and then when rejected decisively steer
in precisely the reverse direction here
is Kamala Harris you'll hear her
complete reversal within 24 hours right
here I agree that the right to vote is
one of the very important components of
citizenship but people who are in
convicted in prison like the Boston
Marathon bomber on death row people who
are convicted of sexual assault they
should be able to vote I think we should
have that conversation do I think that
people who commit murder who people who
are terrorists should be deprived with
their rights yeah oh well that's that's
different isn't it I mean wow what could
have happened to change her mind within
such a short period of time clearly it
must have been new evidence or
compelling arguments or alternatively
everybody looked at her and said a lady
what are you talking about that is some
crazy bleep I think it's the crazy bleep
thing probably so Carla Harris the
reason that she is flailing is because
she's basically a combination of the
worst aspects of Hillary Clinton and
Kirsten Gillibrand yes I understand
she's super intersectional whoo but
aside from her being super
intersectional she got nothing
she says charmless as Hillary Clinton
she laughs just as weirdly and awkwardly
every time she's caught in a lie and she
flips position
like kirsten gillibrand at a twister
party it's amazing it's amazing so I
think that commonly Harris is that the
reason people who judge is gaining
listen this is a wide open race any
Democrat could have grabbed the mantle
here none of them have I think even
people who judge is gonna start receding
the reason I think Budi judge will start
receding is because I think his record
will come under fire and also because
the part that is that the part about
Buddha judge that is attractive is the
fact that he pretends to be a moderate
when he is not as he moves away from
moderation and he will be forced to buy
the other Democratic candidates I think
that he will become less popular over
time meanwhile Elizabeth Warren is
getting owned by the Washington Post
editorial board by the Washington Post
editorial board so she came out with
another one for audacious bold
incredible plans audacious in both our
media synonyms for incredibly stupid she
came out her plan earlier this week to
forgive all student loan debt which
makes perfect sense because we want to
make sure that all the middle income and
middle upper income and rich people in
the country who encourage student loans
at people like Peabody jej who admitted
yesterday that he had a hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt by the way
I think a basic rule of thumb you
shouldn't be elected president if you
still have student loan debt it seems to
me that a very basic function of you
being a responsible adult as you paid
off your student loan debt but put that
aside Elizabeth Warren suggested all the
upper income people who went to college
should have their student loan debt
removed from them which doesn't make any
sense
also it punishes people who actually
spent the money to pay off the student
loan debt I know I've paid off two
student loan debts I paid off my own
from Harvard Law School and I paid off
my wife's medical school loan debts okay
so I'm very well aware of student loan
debt and how much it costs and how you
have to pay for it but those were
choices we make to incur debt and then
we paid off the debt like responsible
humans even the Washington Post is
looking at Elizabeth Warren and going
lady you're too radical for us when you
are too radical for the Washington Post
editorial board you may have lost the
thread of the plot the Washington Post
editorial board says the nation's
households owe almost 1.5 trillion
dollars in student loans according to
the Federal Reserve Bank of New York
this represents a burden on many
families which under mrs. Warren's plan
would disappear completely for 75% of
them and at least partially for 95% of
them no one can accuse miss Warren of
thinking small one of the things I love
about the very
active editorial boards in our nation's
newspapers is when they see a stupid
idea and then they and then they
soft-pedal how stupid the idea is no one
can accuse miss Warren of thinking small
is a synonym for this is a stupid idea
but she's audacious and bold and bold
and audacious and bought a she's an old
what she really needs is a better sense
of proportion is what the Washington
Post says her premise seems to be that
student debt is all burden and no
benefit but this is not true it
represents an investment in skill
acquisition that pays substantial
long-term benefits this is true so I
love that The Washington Post is now
ripping on Elizabeth Warren so she's got
troubles too there's a reason that she
is not launching other candidates in
trouble
apparently beta O'Rourke beta that dudes
in trouble as well why because he's no
longer running against Ted Cruz yeah so
the good news for beta O'Rourke is who's
running against Ted Cruz not the Ted is
a super weak candidate but beta O'Rourke
received the unstinting applause and
accolades of the entire mainstream media
which they hates Ted Cruz with a passion
they hate senator Cruz and so beta rook
I mean he could have been a ham sandwich
note been like this is the greatest ham
sandwich this ham sandwich will probably
save the world this ham sandwich cures
cancer and then as soon as the race is
over they're like this ham sandwich has
mold on it the same sandwich is kind of
gross I feel like it's spoiled
the bread is not high quality that's
what's happening with beta O'Rourke he's
the ham sandwich so beta O'Rourke it's
now found shockingly the media have
somehow tracked down the officers on the
scene of his 1998 DWI that's amazing
he's been in the public view for years
and years and years he was in the public
view running against Ted Cruz for a year
and a half and yet no one could track
down the mysterious police officers who
were there for his DWI until now the
former police officer who arrested beta
Rock for driving drunk in 1998 along
with the sergeant who signed the
incident report both say they believe
now what they reported at the time al
ruck tried to leave the scene of the
wreck he caused a Roark admits he was
intoxicated says there was no
justification for his actions but he has
denied that he tried to flee Beto's DWI
is something he has long publicly and
openly addressed said O'Rourke's
spokesperson but neither the
investigating officer nor his former
supervisor specifically recalls the
events of that night they
they said the report that compiled in
sign is accurate however they say there
is no doubt he tried to leave the scene
of the DWI weird because the media
allowed him to get away with this for
years when he was running against Cruz
suddenly he's running against Joe Biden
and Bernie Sanders and oh well we go now
now we have to report on bado and panels
like dude what happened why are you
ripping on me I'm just ripping this bong
why are you ripping on me and the answer
is he's no longer running against Ted
Cruz okay we'll get to a couple of other
Democratic candidates and then we'll get
to the democratics the Democratic
members of Congress seeking new
subpoenas and all the rest so other
Democratic candidates for president so
he has not declared yet nor should he
but Bill DeBlasio continues to be just
world stupidest human you know one of
the things that I love about New Yorkers
is that they truly believe they're the
smartest people on planet Earth they
really do I mean they believe their city
is the greatest New York City's amazing
they believe they're the smartest people
on planet Earth some New Yorkers are
smart but you guys elected Bill DeBlasio
that was you I didn't do it okay so
don't tell me how smart you are when
you'll like I don't claim that Los
Angelenos are smart we elected Antonio
Villaraigosa to be our mayor and then we
followed that genius move up with Eric
Garcetti I'm not pretending
then my city is full of geniuses but New
Yorkers seem to have this perspective
that their city is completely full of
people with 150 IQs your mayor is this
doofus Bill DeBlasio who announced over
the last 48 hours that he doesn't want
any more buildings made of steel and
glass in the city of New York what are
you made of hemp groundhog corpses what
exactly here's Bill DeBlasio we're going
to introduce legislation to ban the
glass and steel skyscrapers that have
contributed so much to global warming
they have no place in our city or in our
earth anymore if a company wants to
build a big skyscraper they can use a
lot of glass if they do all the other
things needed to reduce the emissions
but putting up monuments to themselves
that harmed our earth and threatened our
future that will no longer be allowed in
New York City
yeah let's tear down the city whoo every
major structure in New York City is made
of two things steel and glass
so where you want to start the Empire
State Building or should we head over to
the Chrysler Building where should we
start with this thing steel and glass my
goodness
apparently people inside the industry
are like I'm what everyone in the real
estate industry was saying what is this
glassy buildings are the rage among
designers you know why cuz they're nice
because when you sit inside a giant
glass building you get to look out over
the world and its really pretty you know
it's not nice giant Gulag style west
east germany cement blocks those were
all the rage in the 1970s they were why
they were seriously ugly de Blasio said
we certainly felt the opposition at the
real estate lobby in these last months
but to the credit of everyone there we
said we don't care how much opposition
there is so good luck with this all he
wants to do is make New York City uglier
uglier
okay the nice nice bill de blasio
okay meanwhile the Democrats are still
trying to push forward with more
subpoenas and investigations against the
Trump administration Adam Schiff is
writing a pee wrote a piece for The
Washington Post about President Trump
and ensuring he's not working for
foreign interests the fact that he is
even still able to show his face in
public after spending years claiming
that he has inside information that
President Trump was a stooge of the
Kremlin is simply incredible
but he has a full piece at The
Washington Post today this dolt saying
that the President of the United States
may in fact be still working for other
outside influences he says that that the
counterintelligence investigations
showed that the president was deceiving
people about Trump Tower Moscow which
means he was really in the pay of the
Russians and all this as many Americans
have expressed deep concerns that
foreign powers especially Russia
cultivated or possessed financial
leverage or influence over President
Trump or his associates why did those
many Americans say that representative
chef may because someone on the House
Intelligence Committee kept going out
there and lying about his inside
information could that be it could that
be the problem but the Democrats are
using this as the jumping-off point to
try and push for more information from
President Trump they want more subpoenas
they want his tax returns now their
claim to get his tax returns is actually
fairly strong just legally speaking the
Democrats do have the power the
legislative branch does have the power
to investigate and in fact there were a
lot of people over the last couple of
weeks talking about the Muller report
who
said that really the power to
investigate things like the Muller
report which may become the basis for
impeachment hearings that shouldn't be
done inside the president's executive
branch that should be done inside the
legislative branch that is what the
separation of powers means I am one of
the people who suggested this that means
that Congress has investigative powers
now the law may be too broad there is
law right now that allows the the house
to request a tax returns from any
private citizen which I believe is too
broad I think that violates privacy
concerns I think it's a bad law and it
should be changed and maybe it violates
the Fourth Amendment's the Constitution
about unreasonable search and seizure
but the law is on the books right now
Democrats do have that law at their
disposal President Trump is trying to
claim executive privilege on a vast
variety of materials now now that is
nothing new Barack Obama tried to claim
executive privilege to shield his
attorney General Eric Holder on
questions about fast and furious that
was overruled by a court I have a
feeling the same thing as in order for
president Trump representative Elijah
Cummings the chairman of the House
Oversight Committee said that the White
House has adopted the untenable position
that it can ignore requests from the
Democratic majority in the house
cummings said in a statement it appears
the President believes the Constitution
does not apply to his white house that
may he mean that he may order officials
at will to violate their legal
obligations that he may obstruct
attempts by Congress to conduct
oversight Cummings was specifically
referring to Carl Kline a former White
House personnel security director who is
subpoenaed by Democrats he was supposed
to be deposed about granting security
clearance to Jared Kushner for example
Trump has told the Washington Post I
don't want people testifying to a party
because that is what they are doing when
they do this meanwhile the
administration on Tuesday didn't fight
it's a man from the Ways and Means
Committee to turn over six years of
President Trump's tax returns by the
close of business now can he actually do
this probably not and the legal record
here is pretty clear there is a case
called Eastland versus United States
servicemen's fund a Supreme Court case
that found that Congress can subpoena
private parties under exactly the sort
of law so I don't think the president's
delay tactics are going to work here
they also plan to fight the house
subpoena a former White House Counsel
Don Magan that's because Don McGann is
in the Moller report and in the Mullah
report it says that Don McGann was
ordered by the president
the United States to lie about certain
things he didn't he refused to lie about
those things and then that was sort of
the end of the story that was used as
the basis for a quasi obstruction
accusation so the Congress wants to hear
direct from again Trump is gonna claim
executive privilege there are a couple
different kinds of executive privilege
the first kind of executive privilege is
the right of the President to prevent
the Congress from overseeing certain
national security needs the Congress
doesn't have a right to oversee the
President on matters of national
security and also protecting the privacy
of White House deliberations because
what you don't want is it made public
every time the president has a
conversation that has public impact that
probably does not apply when you are
talking about the president ordering his
aides to lie or do bad things or come in
a crime or defend him personally that
stuff probably does not apply so I think
that executive privilege claim is
probably going to come up short okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today now this is not exactly a
thing that I like but it's a thing that
is worthy of note and we should be
taking note and I hope that the Trump
administration will formally recognize
the Armenian Genocide today's Armenian
Genocide day April 24th every year is
the date upon which we marked our Meeny
and genocide the American government has
not done it many Western governments
have not done it specifically because
they don't want to tick off the Turks
the Turkish government has long claimed
that the Armenian Genocide is a myth
that is not true the Turkish government
has also suggested repercussions for
anyone who says that the Armenian
genocide took place the repercussions
honestly the West should say screw you
it happened because it did on this date
in 1915 hundreds of Armenian
intellectuals Christians for the most
part or forcibly deported from the
Turkish capital Turkish capital of
Constantinople the number has been
escalated into the thousands most of
these people were eventually murdered
that kicked off the Armenian Genocide
which was the persecution of Christians
Armenians by the Young Turks who were
Muslim they wanted to cleanse the
country of the Troublesome non
co-religionists in preparation for the
new turkey in the aftermath of the
collapse of the Ottoman Empire and
supposedly in order to ensure against
the possibility of the Armenians siding
against the Central Powers in World War
one by the time the genocide was over it
lasted from 1915 all the way to 1923
hundreds of thousands of Armenians had
been killed top range estimates put that
number at 1.5 million there are massive
atrocities including forced death
marches placing
children allegedly aboard ships and then
deliberately sinking them CNN reports
quote while the death toll is in dispute
photographs from the era document some
mass killings some show Ottoman soldiers
posing with severed heads others with
them standing amid skulls in the dirt
the victims are reported to have died in
mass burnings by drowning torture gas
poison disease and starvation children
were reported to have been loaded onto
boats taken out to sea and thrown
overboard rape 2 was frequently reported
now as I say the current dictator of
Turkey who has granted far too much
respect by the Western world he should
not be he is an Islamist radical who
supports terrorist groups like Hamas he
is also a deeply threatening figure in
places like Syria as well as to the
Kurds heir Dolan has threatened multiple
foreign countries for daring to consider
the use of the term Armenian Genocide he
warned he could throw a hundred thousand
Armenian immigrants out of Turkey in
2010 so he is a delight the world did
turn a blind eye while the Armenian
Genocide was occurring
however a German corporal did not in
1939 became addicted he was already
dictator of Germany
he told Nazi officers in 1939 to kill
without mercy in Poland adding allegedly
according to contemporaneous records
quote who after all speaks today of the
annihilation of the Armenians man go
ahead and kill whoever you have to kill
because no one cares rabbi shmuel e-boat
else has said hitler's confidants
learned from turkeys genocide I'll play
book my Sittler strategized his rise to
power
in the early 1920s his lead political
adviser was Max Ehrmann von Schroeder
Richter a young German consular office a
fish officer in Arizona in World War 1 a
region of Ottoman Turkey densely
populated with Armenians turkeys ethnic
cleansing in World War one was well
known and admired by Nazi ideologues in
1923 a journalist named Hans Trump wrote
in the Nazi newspaper hi Matlin these
bloodsuckers and parasites Greeks and
Armenians had been eradicated by the
Turks this chilling praise of genocide
foretold atrocities to come so certainly
the Armenian Genocide is well worthy of
note and I have a lot of sympathy for
Armenian claims particularly against the
current Turkish government okay time for
a thing that a hate
so baby boomers may have ruin America
baby boomers spent all the money and
then they and then they wind about it
and then they taught their children very
little in the way of values and it
appears that their children my
generation Millennials have picked up on
a lot of the self-centeredness of the
baby boomers unfortunately there's a new
article from Business Insider that says
American Millennials have less money
than other generations did at their age
but we are delusional about the amount
of wealth that we have many American
Millennials think they will be
millionaires by middle age they have a
generally positive view about their
finances according to several studies
but research shows that Millennials are
currently behind financially well that
is because they've been told for years
by their parents that if they go to
college and major and lesbian dance
theory they will be millionaires this is
not true this is not true now
income ability in the United States is
still quite strong you can still move up
if you make the decisions but you have
to make those good decisions and your
firm belief that you were born in in a
place where you will be a millionaire
simply by dint of the fact that you are
an American born in America at this time
in place not get off your butt work a
little bit okay other things that I hate
so this is a crazy story today from
pluralist calm a whiteness studies
professor says that white people who
treat all races equally are dangerous a
guest lecturer at Boston University said
last month that white people who judge
others as individuals instead of by the
color of their skin are dangerous
according to a report in the college fix
the lecture was entitled what does it
mean to be white it was given by a
University of Washington professor named
Robin to Angelo a white woman who
presumably should have given up her slot
to a woman of minority descent if she
really wants to make these points and
stop her white privilege from applying
DeAngelo specializes in whiteness
studies whiteness studies great she
added the people who say they've been
taught to treat everyone the same deny
black people their reality as I've
mentioned many times there is no such
thing as your reality there is just the
reality and then your opinion about the
reality if you're being honest you
probably said it she said of being
taught to treat everyone the same your
parents could lecture you to do it but
you don't do it you can't do it there's
no human objectivity
I'll start arguing with MLK then because
this was MLK's perspective this is also
the perspective of the best in Western
civilized values if you want people to
treat each other as members of try
raise things are not going to end well
historically speaking D'Angelo said when
she hears people say they're colorblind
they are revealing their own ignorance
this person doesn't understand basic
socialization this person doesn't
understand culture this person is not
self-aware she said while teaching as a
whiteness professor as a white woman
refusing to give up her slot at a major
university lecturing a bunch of white
kids and I need to give a heads-up to
the white people in the room D'Angelo
said when people of color hear us say
this they're generally not thinking all
right I'm talking to a woke white person
right now usually some version of eye
rolling is going on and a wall is going
up right if you want to be labeled woke
by the intersectional crowd you have to
say I surrender all my perspectives to
you my perspectives are no longer of
consequence I will sit here and shut up
and listen and never say anything again
I have turned myself into a potted plant
upon which Harvey Weinstein will
ejaculate that's basically what people
are looking for
D'Angelo's remarks are of course
diametrically opposed to certain
centralized values of Western
civilization but it's good to know and
it's very exciting to know that there
are professors out there teaching
students that it is very very bad that
it is very very terrible to treat people
equally and not based on the color of
their skin
yes our society may be nearing its
terminus already so we will be back here
tomorrow with the last episode of the
week because Friday is again a Jewish
holiday so I will see you then I've been
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show a woman is suing an uber
driver for refusing to take her to an
abortion meanwhile leftists weep over a
sack full of puppies in a dumpster we
will examine our clinical culture check
it out of Daily wire calm